here in this video we will showcase 10
super powerful beings that venom and the
other symbiotes have defeated which
would mean the ones that were defeated
by null and the all black and others too
we will include the beings from the
crossover events and alternate timelines
as well we won't take much time in this
intro so subscribe to be a part of the
mind cue family and now let's get down
to business
number 10 the cosmic gods gore the
second host to bind with the symbiote
all black was the most infamous girl
formed the ling with the all black after
stealing it from null who was badly
damaged in a battle with a god that gore
eventually killed later on gore adopted
the alliance god the god butcher during
the symbiotes time with him and during
that time he exploited the symbiote's
powers to enslave and slay numerous gods
across the universe god formed his own
mindless obedient army of symbiotic
monsters known as the black berserkers
by using the all black to make numerous
weapons including the notorious
necrosaurus and with it all he killed a
score of gods all over the cosmos
number nine the juggernaut in venom the
madness venom and the juggernaut were
pitched against each other in a lawsuit
later the juggernaut kidnaps venom's
girlfriend venom then comes to the
rescue and clashes with the mutant but
gets pummeled and defeated however later
he merges with a strange sludge and with
that he gets a strange new virus which
makes this a bit more powerful powerful
enough to go toe to toe with the
juggernaut after a lengthy battle the
juggernaut retreats and runs away
claiming that he isn't getting paid
enough for such an abuse
number 8 the hulk in issue number 4 of
1989's what if storyline peter parker
was trying to get the venom symbiote off
of his suit but was unable to even with
the help of dr reed richards and dr
strange the story continues with the
hulk in a mindless rampage in new york
with thor trying to subdue him then
doctor strange opens a portal to trap
the hulk in another dimension but
spider-man swoops in and pulls the hulk
away from him
and in that instance the venom symbiote
merges with the hulk and when thor later
manages to rip off the symbiote off of
hulk it is revealed that the symbiote
has done away with the hulk's essence
and consume all the gamma radiation as
well as the excess flesh from the
transformation leaving only bruce banner
behind
number seven the avengers and earth's
heroes in issues of the king and black
storyline null and his army of symbiotes
invade the earth and battle against all
of earth's mightiest heroes which
include the avengers x-men the fantastic
four and others as well in this
desperate attempt to fight off the
symbiote hive mind we see all of them
slowly one by one getting either beat
down or enveloped by the symbiotes and
trapped in the hive mind of the klintar
number six thor all father thor has
always been a huge four against the
symbiotes with the earliest recorded
battle of him fighting off grendel and
his mother the two symbiote dragons sent
to earth in the past although in this
early event thor manages to defeat them
and sever the connections of the clinton
with null thus allowing them to become
independent however in the king and
black thor with the power of the all
father was unable to win against the god
of the symbiotes who was null and was
stopped by him leaving the thunder god
incapacitated until help arrived
number five the sentry in the same comic
run of king in black while the battle
was turning bad for the sight of earth's
protectors there was a slight glimmer of
hope when the sentry who is one of the
most powerful characters in the marvel
universe entered the bell and took
another way to be burned at the surface
of the sun sentry causes some major
damage against the symbiote god before
null reverses the power play and grabs
him out of midair and after calling him
out for taking down carnage now rips
sentry in half absorbs devoid the
darkness part of sentry's massive power
and becomes even more powerful
number four superman superman met venom
in the dc slash marvel crossover all
axes
with the symbiote pulling up a dramatic
upset against a man of steel it is
difficult to envision venom posing a
serious threat to dc's most powerful
hero yet that is exactly what happened
in a 1990s crossover
when a befall venom became trapped in
metropolis he immediately went about
ravaging the city in a pursuit of
answers this leads to the man of steel
confronting the symbiote and then
fighting one-on-one with venom fresh
from the victory over juggernaut he
blinds superman with his webbing but
then using hit vision to free his eye
superman gives chase he certainly gets
his share of punches but venom is barely
staggered declaring that he is beginning
to hate superman as much as he does
spider-man venom grabs a man of steel
and begins to smother the kryptonian to
death with his tendrils only for him to
be saved by spider-man later on
number three the young enigma force
back again to the storyline of the king
in black the dark god null was in the
end defeated by the enigma force infused
with eddie brock who chose the form of
venom to take him to the core of the sun
and burn away all the darkness but this
wasn't the first time the enigma force
fought against null millions of years in
the past it was revealed that the battle
was in fact the other way around and
that a younger form of the enigma force
was defeated by the gods of the
symbiotes
number two galactus so the devourer of
worlds is yet another one on this list
galactus who is widely acknowledged as
one of the most powerful beings in the
marvel universe has succumbed to the
power of a symbiote although the
symbiote in question was attached
another superpowered being in the form
of ego the living planet in the
beginning of the battle all black was
attached to galactus but then later on
the all-black transferred to the living
planet transforming him into the necro
world then ego proceeded to devour
galactus finally making him pay for all
the planets that he had destroyed
and number one the celestials and of
course the celestials are one of the
original victims and also one of the
latest to fall against null and his
symbiotes in the beginning of time there
was devoid and when the seventh cosmos
was created by the celestials all the
slight intruded into null's domain and
hence from that time on he waged war on
all creation
after seeing the immense power of the
celestials he created the all-black the
necro sword and with it he decapitated
the head of one celestials whose served
head would later become nowhere then in
the king and black storyline it was
shown that null had settled the score
with the other celestials as well and
enslaved them using his symbiotes
so that's 10 super powerful beings that
were destroyed defeated killed and
retreated away from symbiotes so i hope
you have enjoyed watching this video
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam